Buenas tardes con Don gratuito querido y
el test ya lo has hecho quieres hacerlo
es un joven de 26 años que convive con
el VIH desde su nacimiento hoy es
activista en la principal ong de Río de
Janeiro
mis padres no hablan mucho sobre esta
cuestión lo que yo escuchaba en la calle
y en la escuela era Siempre sobre el
sida
y siempre de una forma muy pesada una
forma que yo considero equivocada
hoy se vino coordina un grupo de
voluntarios que realizan pruebas
diagnósticas en la calle de forma
gratuita el resultado sale en tan solo
15 minutos
salió bien gracias a Dios chao
durante su mandato paralizó 12 programas
de prevención del Sida y cortó la
entrega de 615 millones de dólares
destinados a la compra de medicamentos
además en la última década el perfil
racial de esta enfermedad ha cambiado en
la actualidad el 62% de los fallecidos
Son afrodescendientes
creo que eso acontece principalmente por
la cuestión del racismo estructural
nos miran como si fuésemos personas
peligrosas criminales especialmente en
los centros
A falta de campañas efectivas los
contagios entre los jóvenes aumentaron
un 50% se trata de un claro retroceso
según el portavoz de esta ong
la cuestión del VIH una gran
preocupación porque sabemos que la falta
de continuidad en el tratamiento lleva
el Punto de partida
hay que hacer todo en otro esquema para
que el paciente consiga la inmunidad y
el virus no se replique
[Música]
la esperanza de este colectivo es que el
nuevo gobierno de Lula retome la
inversión y las políticas de lucha
contra el sida